When we discuss the
rolling of the wheel,
we chose a reference
frame fixed to the ground.
So that was what we called frame
A. And in that reference frame,
the motion of the point P on
the rim was quite complicated.
Now what we'd like to look at
it in the reference frame moving
with the center of mass.
And we call that frame cm.
Now the picture
there is much easier
because the object is--
in that reference frame,
the center of mass
is not moving.
And the point P on
the rim, the object
is just undergoing
circular motion.
So in that frame, the
velocity of that point P
in the center of mass frame
is just tangent to the circle.
And as the object moves
around, at a later time,
the velocity is
always tangential.
And in this reference frame,
it's just pure circular motion.
And we know that the speed
in that reference frame
is given by the radius of the
wheel times the rate d phi
to dt.
And here let's define the
variable theta this way.
And so, in this frame
what's happening
is pure circular motion.
Now we know our law of
addition of velocity
tells us that the velocity
in the frame fixed
to the ground of that point
is equal to the velocity
of the center of mass
plus the velocity
of the object, the
point on the run
in the center of mass frame.
Now what we want
to do now is draw
a picture which illustrates this
law of addition of velocities.